if freedom can't win over something so
innocuous and worse the benefits are so
wide then you can't win at all my name's
Jeff Dermer
I am the Managing Partner of Dermer
Baron a law firm and we represent the
Southern California mobile food vendors
Association an association of 130 or so
gourmet food trucks based in Southern
California the city of Monrovia is a
small city next to Pasadena in LA County
and early this year they rushed through
a new mobile food ordinance - trucks
can't be on the same block at the same
time vending or time limits times of day
an Old Town ban a residential area
banned so in California you're not a lot
banned Mobile vending that's a state law
and Monrovia is elected officials went
to the newspaper and say we're getting
out in front of this it's unfair
competition they don't pay taxes that
they just come and go and we stand with
our old town merchants and so it's
perfect they're admitting that it's a
competitive ordinance which is illegal
you're talking about office parks so the
captive audience business model of
really high prices and a lousy product
and of course if I could put a truck
that has a similar product or better
product at a similar price and people
eat there yes that is disruptive and is
it unfair competition well I don't think
there's anything unfair about it the
problem is is that your food isn't good
enough the legal climate is much better
now than it has been in the past and
it's been a slow slog there's some big
cases in 2006 2008 2009 in Orange County
LA County challenging various ordinances
and every of your challenge to my
knowledge has been successful and la has
got a an injunction against Pro
prohibitions on private property to city
of La a lot of cities really like what
the food trucks bring the diversity the
quality food the sort of street fair
atmosphere and so they're being really
supportive and that's creating
competition
whereas years years ago they
his crackdown the police were busting
guys you don't really see the police
busting people as the Health Department
in LA County the number of trucks has
actually gone down because the
traditional taco trucks serve
construction and construction has been
destroyed by this recession so the
number of trucks in operations down 15
20 percent but this this sort of gourmet
industry didn't exist more than two
three years ago and so that's growing
everywhere it's last year's very fast
growth if anything I think it's going to
allow more people to become chefs and
should increase the success and failures
just the number of people the more
opportunity and anytime you do that
anytime you knock down barriers and
entry to get innovation and innovation
and is almost uniformly good everybody
has a little libertarian in them and in
this case the right doesn't want rules
like on businesses and the left wants
cultural diversity and so you've got
some of the pacs both those together and
once you sell it that way it's very hard
to be against it it's a matter of the
most basic freedom a freedom to eat what
you want a freedom to innovate a freedom
to use your streets your sidewalks and
in your land in a way you see fit and in
this case it's a choice of freedom over
almost nothing it's not is there gonna
be a bomb going off it's that is this
restaurant going to lose five cents on
the dollar or this landlord gonna lose
his land or am I scared because I can't
control something in this city limit if
freedom can't win over something so
innocuous and where's the benefits are
so wide then they can't win at all
you